can i tell you a little secret so
my ex used to say to me all the time
that my alter ego was little kim because
i had like this whole crush on you
and i said i just want one day of life
where i can put that diamond bikini on
that she had on
and that fur coat and just like rock it
like she did i just want that confidence
i want that
oh just one day i'll be undressed
in the bra well i can tell you a little
secret
it's it's really it was really hard for
me to get there
was it no yeah i'm very shy
i was always very shy i was always very
timid
american gangster trap queens is back
for season two this time you are going
to be narrating
why'd you want to take this on why'd you
want to do this project so
um i i love all these girls
um for the tenacity and for their
strength and for
pushing through um in times where
they had to do what they had to do i
mean i think everyone in the world
can identify with these women everybody
wants to be rich everyone wants to be
famous everyone wants you know
money fast but a lot of times we make
the wrong decisions
on how to make that happen
i think you know there's so many women
across the world
and that can identify with these women
in their stories
and you see how like one bad decision or
one
like ill-timed decision can just
make the whole trajectory of your life
turn down like that
just one one wrong turn and it happens
but
for me i feel like these girls are also
in a sense kind of like heroes and kind
of
um you know what i mean because you a
one
they may be saving a little girl in a
hood right now who's thinking of going
down the same path
can i tell you a little secret so my ex
used to say to me all the time that my
alter ego was little kim
because i had like this whole crush on
you and i said
i just want one day of life where i can
put that diamond bikini on that she had
on
and that fur coat and just like rock it
like she did i just want that confidence
i want that
oh just one day i
well i could tell you a little secret
it's it's really it was really hard for
me to get there
was it yeah i'm very shy
i was always very shy i was always very
timid i was always this little girl with
this tiny voice
and my babysitter used to tell my mom
she's so quiet we
should be talking and we can't hear what
she's saying
so it was kind of like my ulta eagle
because they like you got to speak up
and i'd be like
hey hear me now
[Laughter]
you didn't have to talk loud well there
you go
i never ever thought that i never would
have thought like that you were real shy
and scary that was like me
having to kind of do that you know what
i mean like it's almost like i had to i
had to push myself every time every
night but it it um it became second
nature to me
i've been going for
so of course you know you're an icon you
got hits after hits after hits after
hits
so are you working on new music is that
in your head space right now and like
what inspires you
right i actually am i i'm actually
i love music so i'm always inspired any
little thing can inspire me my daughter
danced into tick-tock songs because
me my daughter loves zig-zag oh gosh um
you know this time i i'm
i've been afraid like a lot of people
say my my life and my story is so
interesting that if i put it on music
people will go crazy you know i'm kind
of like in between that spot
this is a lot of stuff that i want to
talk about but sometimes you like
nah like i like i i'm gonna erase it and
throw it out
by the way how's that precious little
royal anyway she's
awesome she's doing excellent in school
i'm
so proud of her i was in i had to do
school with her the other morning
are you homeschooling because of the
hand gimmick oh boy yes
i was tight as hell but i was up there
with her i was hanging in here
i didn't want my my bestie because
that's my bestie
yes and and then um she she got a
hundred and
eight plus at the end of the day for
all her work and i was just so proud of
her now that
this this can be this being a mama now
like does that
shape how you like look at your music or
what influences your music or what
empowerment you like do you look at
things differently
kind of sort of you know kind of sort of
but
you know in any woman i said that they
didn't change a little bit when they had
a baby then
we might need to question their mama's
skills a little bit because you have to
change a little bit
you do you have to just have to but
because i try to be strategic and you
know i like to think i'm an intelligent
girl even though sometimes i do the
dumbest stuff but we all do
you know but i you know trying to
use my intelligence to try to find a
happy medium somewhere
you know what i mean um i
feel like my fans are very
they they will be understanding but also
more importantly my daughter's
understanding she is
so smart she understands
she knows okay that's a cuss word or
this is that don't say that
but she still knows how to enjoy the
music that that makes sense
yeah like she just zoom on past that now
you said she loves to dance on tick tock
so it sounds like she's got creativity
flowing through her veins
already oh she's super she's a super
superstar
okay so what are you gonna do if she
comes to you and says mama i wanna do
what you do
i want to be a rapper i want to be in
entertainment
well i have to support her because
you know i can't be a hypocrite i will
some of the stuff that i know now i will
i will guide her in directors
that she don't make the same mistakes
that i need
also you know i may suggest
a different route than me politely
gently suggest i hear what you're saying
now kim you know i've been looking at
your instagram and i saw that you and mr
papers had the holidays together how is
everything going everything's wonderful
um happy family it was storming
christmas eve
that's where i live so i open up the
door
the whole town is black so that was my
christmas eve
black out and it didn't come on
christmas day
either it was it was bittersweet
because her dad you know mm-hmm
okay he had to come in um her dad had to
come and get us
um even though that was the plan anyway
but then sooner
and we ended up uh we went to his house
and we spent
the rest of the holidays there girl
that's okay then you didn't have to put
it on you and like he didn't say oh you
just want me to come get you you have a
good reason so that's good
that's all right um so kim you know he
was he was on his way anyway
i was very very proud of him it was
really really
i like to hear that i really like to
hear that i like that you're happy
um and you know we've been we've been
hanging with you for a minute here at et
and what we like to do kim we like to
take a little march down memory lane
and show people the first time that we
ever interviewed them so i want you to
take a look at this
this is you backstage at the mtv vmas
after winning
for lady marmalade i really want to give
props and thanks to a woman that i kind
of forgot i didn't forget but oh you're
just so excited
patty lavelle look how cute you are
kim what would you tell what advice
would you have
for that girl right there
girl you did everything perfect
it was so good it was a good one i was
really proud of myself at that
that time it was i was having fun and
you know i was doing what i wanted to do
you know you do what you want when you
puppy and you
so i was having fun and i think that you
know
you know we just young girls just
enjoying
our success enjoying our you know
love for what we do which is music and
performing
and money and just enjoying it
that was one of the first times i think
we all saw like these women from
different genres come together and have
a real girl power moment
yeah i'm saying like yeah it's not real
oh yeah we were like that then like we
just
everybody wanted to work with everybody
that we all wanted to just
have girl time girl moment even on
camera
off camera like we just wanted to work
with everybody because
we just saw fun in that yeah and we saw
we saw like dad this girl is talented
she's beautiful she's dope and we wanted
to
celebrate that and embrace it
okay one more we were with you on the
set of a magazine photo shoot
um and so here's this one i am all about
fashion
you know little camera of course that's
all i'm associated with
sometimes even more than my music and
that's kind of a problem but
hopefully they'll both uh equal itself
out oh this is my
one of my favorites i mean that face
beat is everything that makeup is
everything it was so
that's that's like one of my favorite
favorite favorite favorite photo shoots
you remember it i remember that i love
that photo shoot it was like with the
doll baby um
they made a skirt out of teddy bears
they actually made that skirt
on the set i think it was like a dng
skirt or something like that it was it
was a name brand skirt but they actually
build on it
where do you get your fashion sense and
because you've of course been known for
starting trends starting fashion trends
people you know wanting to follow what
you do so where does that come from
i used to always tell everybody like i i
watched my mom
come in and my mom was so stylish and i
used to i'm like oh when i get out i
want to walk like her
it started from her walk like her walk
was fierce honey
you had a really nice walk my mom used
to take trips a lot and she always used
to wear these big sunglasses
and they were so dope like i look at the
sunglasses that she wore then and i'm
like
they look like now you know what i mean
um my mom kind of reminds me i always
said my mom
looked like diana ross back then there
you know um
she did she really didn't know i wish i
could find some pictures
always obsessed with this the movie
mahogany and i think
i think as a baby like a baby my mom
said i would just watch that movie
it would make me quiet and i'll just be
watching it and maybe i thought
she was my mother yeah there you go
and it was so fashionable there you go
yeah yeah it was
fashionable yeah that fashion in here
unmatched unmatched unmatched diana ross
was so glamorous in that movie
yay kim thank you so much it's so good
to see you
i'm um very excited to talk to you
because i just been a fan
forever so thank you